it's good to see john gray we love
seeing him in purple and for
john it's his 20th start of the season
the numbers are great control stats for
him they've improved over the course of
the year and this is to first base
kron's got it little help from greg good
start 3-1
then he hits it on the ground to short
time over to first from trevor story two
ground outs and that'll bring up ian hat
great start for greg
he stripes out he in half a one two
three first
oh wow this was the end of the inning
kerwin danley
is back locked up is what we're being
told
unfortunately kerwin's gonna have to get
treatment on that immediately so they're
gonna go to a three-man crew starting
pitcher for the cubs is sir alec takes
him out for the 22nd time this year 10th
time as a starting pitcher an rbi single
in the sixth last night he was one for
five
and he starts this ball game out with
the ball toward right center field you
know he's going to try to stretch it
here he goes towards second and rymel in
with a double
he's aggressive on the fastball he gets
one elevated
and the moment that ball found grass you
know he was on his way to second base
here's brendan rodgers
and this ball toward that gap and left
center and it's gonna drop takia got a
good read back-to-back doubles
one-nothing colorado well mills is known
for ground ball so it's a good sign for
rocky's hitters that the location is up
this is a
65 mile an hour curveball up in the
strike zone and rogers is trying to just
basically hit it as hard as he can
splits the gap
top and nobody out
reads it properly
there's one out and that'll bring up
story
and
this will get the job done infield is
back
so trevor got it in play and he picks
off his 50th rbi of the season shooting
up in colorado janeshway fargus the
batter cubs have a scoring chance two
men on one away
this is geneshui fargus good stop
mcmahon did he get the added second he
did
boy that was another terrific play and
you need not wonder why
the defensive run saved category
features ryan mcmahon a top third
baseman
outstretched quick spin you have to be
so athletic mcmahon six foot three good
job by roger staying on the bag we know
the neighborhood rule is no longer in
play
two nothing rockies third inning here at
coors field alec mills the cubs pitcher
right-handed batter to face john gray
next pitch is a cold strike three and
just like that
alec mills will head back to the dugout
second strikeout of the night for john
gray 2-2 pitch swing and a miss got him
on a breaking ball and john gray has
fanned the first two here in the third
inning and this is what separates johnny
he doesn't want that location you can't
look back into diaz and like whoops
no that's that's exactly right buried to
the back foot of the lefty it looks like
a strike out of the hand and just
disappears now wilson contreras 3-2
pitch swing and a miss john gray threw
the curve ball and contreras was out in
front and gray strikes out the side give
him four on the night
top of the fourth two nothing rockies
ian happ against john gray
hot shot mcmahon's got it
have a night with the glove 24.
that is a really difficult low line
drive backhand and keep it in the glove
two outs first and third
swing and a miss got him with the curve
ball and john gray his fan six mcmahon
down at second now for elias diaz
diaz
out to fergus backtracking
makes the catch tagging is mcmahon
heading for third and they got it
the tag from wisdom and a big time throw
from
janeshway
good on you janeshway fargus and does a
really nice job getting behind this one
retreats quickly squares up behind it
mcmahon tries to take advantage and he
really gets a lot on that throw
boom boom out and the bases are loaded
for patrick wisdom who's two for two
wisdom gets a hold of one now to left
back goes tapia to the wall to the track
leaps does that and doesn't hold on to
it had it in his glove and it dropped
out
and three runs will come in and the cubs
take the lead
winston put a charge in it and the
runners were going with two outs
and ortega contreras and have come home
almost a circus catch by tapia in left
field but almost doesn't get it done
came back to the slider one more time
this one stays on the plate wisdom does
a real nice job going down to get it
almost
knocks it out here a heck of an effort
by tapia but as he hits the wall cannot
secure that baseball right-hander joey
comes on justine making his 24th
appearance
get a ground ball here andrew romine
pitch hitting for miles
is out four to three the one-two pitch
swung on and missed expanded the strike
zone did ortega and jolish shaseem gets
the k slider he's always had a great one
ortega missed that one by at least the
flow there he goes breaking for third
pitches a strike and
the throw down to third goes into left
field coming on into score is contreras
[Music]
but
it is strike three on the batter
and so it doesn't matter boy everybody
kept on playing and the strikeout will
be recorded the run does not count matt
duffy at first base with a lead-off
single he's a board for ortega and the
top of the order there goes duffy swung
out of mist a second duffy's up
do not run on elias diaz not a wise move
the big arm of elias diaz comes through
again as duffy's caught trying to steal
for the first down
and
swung on and missed so now there's two
outs
hard shot there's mcmahon again
how good a game has he played on defense
to the bottom of the ninth we go manny
rodriguez on the pitch and he will face
five six and seven in the order
first pitch swinging right back to
rodriguez over to first
cubs win three to two
patrick wisdom the three run double in
the third and the bullpen makes it stand